dans la famille des ordinateurs
portables je voudrais asus astuces avec
une toute nouvelle machine qui est
vraiment mais vraiment super rebelle
c'est celle-là la référence parce qu'il
faut les retenir les références parfois
c'est le zenbook flip s c'est surtout le
modèle une x360 et 11 oui parce qu'il ya
modèle 370 mais aujourd'hui on parle de
371 il est super fin il est pas fait
pour tout le monde il est peut-être fait
pour vous peut-être pas ce que je vous
conseille donc c'est de venir regarder
cette vidéo jusqu'au bout pour savoir
cette nouvelle machine d'asus est fait
pour vous c'est une machine qui est
vraiment extrêmement belle définition
sont vraiment top
les livrer dans ce petit carton moi ici
j'ai un chargeur us mais rassurez-vous
vous aurez un chargeur français soyez
rassuré sur ce point on va donc se faire
tout de suite
le test de ce nouvel ordinateur de asus
mais avant toute chose et si ce n'est
pas déjà fait vous invite à venir vous
abonner en tout cas sur le petit bouton
rouge se situe juste là pour tout savoir
de la critique parce que oui il ya plein
de belles choses et qu'on voit en 2021
j'ai hâte on a tous hâte de donner 21 à
quel point eh bien il va y avoir encore
plus de choses beaucoup plus cool de
très belles évolutions donc abonnez-vous
dès maintenant pour ne rien louper
c'est toujours d'une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec soeur chaque
sorte sharks
c'est un vpn qui va venir vous protéger
lorsque vous allez vous connecter à
internet
il va venir éviter les fluctuations de
prix lorsque vous allez venir acheter en
ligne des billets d'avion réserver une
voiture il va également venir vous
protéger lorsque vous allez vous
connecter sur un wifi public dans un
hôtel par exemple un mcdonald's ou je ne
sais quoi encore en venant cryptée et
sécuriser vos données
elle vous permettra d'accéder à vos
sites web préférés qu'ils sont bloqués
par un g au blocage notamment des
contenus bibliothèque de netflix
netflix us netflix japon si vous êtes au
japon netflix europe et même d'autres
sites comme my canal et compagnie ou
vous ne pourriez pas avoir accès
si vous êtes à l'étranger et il a osé
pouvoir y avoir accès avec un seul
abonnement vous pouvez vous connecter
sur un nombre illimité d'appareils en
même temps puisque votre application est
disponible sur pc mac ios android sur
votre smart tv sur apple tv sur chrome
firefox pour xbox ou encore compétition
vous avez une assistance 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 et vous êtes satisfait
ou remboursé dans les 30 jours qui
suivent aux souscriptions et en plus il
n'y a absolument aucune conservation de
vos données sur chaque vous propose des
services en plus comme sur chaque alerte
où vous allez recevoir une alerte dès
que vos données auront fuité sur le web
ce qui vous alertera fournir modifier
vos mots de passe et vous allez pouvoir
effectuer vos recherches sur internet
ont toute confidentialité sans publicité
ni trace je vous invite donc à venir
découvrir et à essayer sans charges nous
a mis un lien en bas dans la description
profiter de 84 % de remise et de quatre
mois offerts
je sais pas si c'est votre dada et
ordinateurs portables mais celui là il
est vraiment mais vraiment super beau or
là déjà vous retrouver vraiment quelque
chose qui est distinctif chez asus côte
avec des sacs concentriques qui partent
de asus et qui vont loin loin loin loin
ça c'est vraiment typique un de la
marque et une fois de plus c'est du plus
bel effet j'aime beaucoup
il est surtout extrêmement fins vous en
rendrez compte sur la partie avant tout
ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est les
finitions qu'on va avoir ici premier
point lorsque vous l'ouvrez il vient se
surélever ce qui va vraiment venir jouer
déjà au niveau de l'aération l'air va
mieux circuler sur le dessous pour la
ventilation et pour maintenir
l'ordinateur à bonne température et ça
vient en plus ajoute en termes de
confort lorsque vous allez venir taper
sur votre ordinateur
nous on fait un truc est vraiment
magnifique que vous voyez ci là avec le
livret que vous retrouvez ici est
également sur le côté ici c'est
biseautés s'est découpé au diamant
s'enliserait métal ça donne vraiment du
cash et c'est super super super beau et
ça contribue vraiment à l'esthétique de
ce produit vous le retrouvez tous les
côtés sur l'avant au niveau de la
charnière sur le haut j'allais
connectique vous retrouvez d'un peu
partout
j'aime beaucoup les finitions je trouve
très très bon et en plus c'est un ordi
qu'elle ait jamais fait à peine 1 kg 2
on en plus j'estime certification
militaire contre les chutes et les
vibrations éviter quand même de jeter
par terre ça pourrait être un peu ballot
je vous parlais de cette charnière qui
vient soulever l'ordinateur lorsque vous
l'ouvrez comme ça elle vous permet de
faire beaucoup plus de choses parce que
oui cette charnière gaulliste elle vous
permet de surélever votre pc lorsque
vous avez l'ouvrir mais également de le
transformer votre pc devient donc une
tablette que vous allez pouvoir utiliser
très facilement pour la productivité
je voulais dit il s'appelle zenbook flip
s flipo peut donc le flipper et
transformer on tourne ici sur un windows
10 pro vous avez deux modes soit un mode
ordinateur qui peut standard tel que
vous le connaissez soit en mode tablette
intègre et vous pouvez faire le choix de
mettre le mode tablette en mode tablette
ou de mecs le mode pc en mode tablette
on comprenait un peu l'histoire ça vient
compléter les usages vous apporter une
nouvelle forme d'utilisation tout en
sachant que le clavier est complètement
déconnecté lorsque vous utilisez en mode
tablette qui dit mode tablette dit
forcément écran tactile et là où asus a
été très malins ils vous ont mis ici sur
le côté le bouton pour venir l'allumer
et l'éteindre autant lorsque vous l'avez
en mode pc vous pouvez appuyer sur un
bouton sur l'eau ici mais lorsque vous
transformant votre tablette si votre
bouton on off se situer au niveau du
clavier et bien ce sera un petit peu la
gala pour me retrouver non du coup ce
qu'ils ont fait et ce qui est vraiment
très malin qu'un sens et qu on le
positionne la et
il est positionné là en mode tablette
vous pouvez venir l'allumé layton comme
vous le souhaitez à tout moment bien
pensé et très pratique
ici on a un écran oled uhd hdr 3840 par
2160 pixels un écran 100% dci p3 avec
une luminosité maximale de 400 dit un
écran certifié pantone également
certifié lutter contre la lumière bleue
le clavier est également très pratique à
utiliser bon retour de touche ici vous
voyez un clavier qwerty me khalid et
vous en france vous aurez un clavier
azerty
c'est un modèle qui viennent l'étranger
pour la démonstration vous l'aurez
compris on essaie un très grand track
pack est super agréable à venir utiliser
un doigt ou à deux doigts et en plus
vous avez le num pad vous n'avez qu'à
puis sur le côté et vous retrouvez votre
pavé numérique et surtout ici on
retrouve un clavier bord à bord les
bords on était vraiment réduit pour
laisser la place belle à toutes vos
touches ce qui vient ajouter en
praticité et en confort vos parleurs se
retrouve sous votre ordinateur juste ici
sans être complètement révolutionnaire à
l'expérience audio est pas mal on va se
mettre un petit morceau pour vous
puissiez vous en rendre compte quand
même mieux de pouvoir écouter
directement
voilà alors c'est compliqué j'ai c'est
au travers d'une vidéo comme ça que se
rendent compte
vous avez bien votre haut parleurs là
pour le signal droit celui là pour le
gauche a donc de la spatialisation là
j'ai poussé à fond qualitativement aux
récents des haut parleurs d'ordinateur
on n'est pas sorti complètement
révolutionnaire du fait qu'on les ait en
dessous et bien on perd un peu en termes
de directivité on va perdre un peu en
termes de précision aussi de notamment
au niveau des aigus lorsque vous posez
sur une table leçon va se réfléchir pour
revenir jusqu'à vous attention si vous
souhaitez branché ici un casque filaire
et bien vous ne pouvez pas comment les
ordinateurs qui est extrêmement fin et
bien au niveau des connectiques vous
n'avez nulle part deux prises jack vous
pourrez bien néanmoins ici à péret un
casque en bluetooth
niveau connectique vous y retrouver une
prise hdmi deux prises usb c'est
thunderball quatre dont une des deux
vous servira à venir charger votre
ordinateur tandis que l'autre côté vous
retrouver uniquement une prise usb à
trois points 2 on n'est pas ici sur un
pc qui est dédié pour les créatifs donc
pas de lecteur de carte sd le truc que
je veux dire un petit peu reproché ici
c'est que vous avez uniquement 2 usb
c'est thunderball 4 ce qui fait que
lorsque vous êtes en train de venir
charger votre ordinateur avec votre
chargeur 65 watts et bien il ne vous
reste quoi il ne vous reste plus qu'une
seule prise de disponible ça c'est un
peu dommage si vous avez besoin par
exemple de brancher un disque
dur externe en thunderbolt 4 eh bien il
vous reste plus grand chose en terme de
connectique ça m'aurait semblé bien du
côté droit de l'ordinateur de retrouver
à côté de la prise usb à une prise usb
c'est thunderball 4 et puisque je vous
parle du bloc de charge 65 watts on va
se parler un petit peu autonomie ils ont
même été jusqu'à vous écrire 65 watts
iciec côté très design c'est assez
rigolo on nous annonce ici 15h
d'autonomie alors 15 heures d'autonomie
ça dépend de vous des programmes de tout
ce que vous allez faire sur utilisation
poussée
vous serez bien évidemment en dessous
des 10 heures la réalité va venir se
situer entre les deux entre 10h et 15h
ça va dépendre une fois de plus de votre
utilisation mais surtout ce qui est très
rassurant c'est que grâce à son bloc de
charge 65 watts vous rechargez de 0 à 60
% ont seulement 49 minutes et en plus de
ça vous avez une visite charge en usb
c'est vous pouvez donc utiliser une
power banques pour venir recharger votre
ordinateur ou alors encore un chargeur
d'un autre smartphone sans risquer
d'endommager la batterie de votre pc
si je suis par exemple en déplacement ou
dans un train ou je ne sait où encore
que je n'ai pas de prise pour bien
branché et que je commence à manquer un
peu de batterie et bien je peux brancher
sur ma pauvre banques et continuer à
l'utiliser avoir une belle machine éric
hamel écran ça c'est bien mais ce qui
est important c'est la performance ici
vous retrouvez un intel core i7 2 11e
génération ce giga de ram un terrain de
stockage en ssd pcie et côté graphique
vous avez une intel iris 10 ici pas de
carte graphique séparée ce qui lui
permet donc de gagner en compacité
d'avoir un ordinateur extrêmement fin
mai ce qui nous permettra pas par contre
de venir faire tourner beaucoup
d'applications qui nécessite des
ressources graphiques donc pour du
montage vidéo cet ordinateur n'est pas
nécessairement fait pour vous si vous
êtes vidéaste c'est pas pour vous si
vous souhaitez utiliser un lightroom
photoshop avec beaucoup de calme c'est
pas nécessairement fait pour vous non
plus la plus une machine ici qui se
destinent pour de la bureautique
familiale professionnelle ici ce qu'on
est recherché c'est la polyvalence un pc
vous pouvez aussi bien utiliser à votre
travail très facilement que le soir pour
venir regarder un film une série et sur
netflix sur ce que vous voulez une
machine nomade une machine compacte une
machine qu'on peut emmener partout avec
soi mais qui malgré tout ne manquera pas
de puissance si ce n'est au niveau de
l'affichage graphique pour des usages
plus poussées comme je disais
au niveau de la photo et de la vidéo
tout en sachant que c'est un choix qu'a
fait injuste de ne pas vous mettre deux
cartes graphiques ce qui leur permet de
gagner en autonomie pour répondre aux
usages que je vous ai cités justement on
a en plus ici du wifi 6 avec la
technologie wifi stabilizer qui permet
d'optimiser la gestion du flux en ce
moment fait beaucoup de télétravailler
cette machine pourra répondre justement
à cet usage
avec de l'ia noise cancelling sur tous
vos appels en gros l'idée c'est que vous
êtes chez vous vous télétravail et le
chien aboie et bien on ne l'entendra pas
ça va être annulée le signal du chien
vous avez vos enfants qui sont en train
de jouer un peu plus loin ils font
beaucoup de bruit ça viendra nul et le
signal de vos enfants va devenir
connaître votre voix pour éliminer tous
les bruits parasites extérieur puisqu'on
parle de vision vous retrouver ici une
webcam en 720p avec la technologie 3d
tmr qui va venir optimiser la couleur
pour la rendre plus fidèles c'est vrai
que l'écran tactile est très cool répond
vraiment bien marche super bien
personnellement j'aime beaucoup et donc
ici un pc qui est intéressant de la part
d'asus si vous devez vous positionnez
c'est pour usage de la polyvalence
travaillé chez vous travaillé au bureau
pouvoir le faire flipper pour
transformer en une tablette sans perte
de performance amoureux de vidéos de
photos avec beaucoup de calques passé si
votre chemin si vous êtes des amoureux
de bureautique vous gérez de la
productivité familiale
si vous en avez un usage professionnel
si vous souhaitez une bonne machine
fiable suffisamment puissante endurante
et surtout très polyvalente la fusée
m'boup flip f peut être fait pour vous
moi perso j'aime bien je suis vraiment
très amoureux ses finitions que je
trouve extrêmement bien fait c'est une
machine qui est vendue au tarif de 1799
euros ce qui vous intéresse jamie les
liens en bas dans la description et à
vous de me dire comment vous la trouvez
est-ce que vous avez déjà un ordinateur
d'asus est ce que vous avez pourquoi pas
un smartphone d'asus parce qu asus fait
beaucoup plus que des pc comment vous le
trouvez celui là est ce que vous aimez
le système fleet c'est quelque chose que
vous utilisez que vous pourriez utiliser
tout ce qui est intéressant c'est que le
marché du pc était en décroissance
depuis plus de dix ans et là ça y est il
reprend un petit peu de couleurs
peut-être à cause du conflit mans
peut-être que le coc vide à aider entre
sept machines je trouve très cool pas
fait pour tout le monde mais bien réussi
mis à part ces quelques petits points
que je vous ai cités notamment au niveau
de la connectique wi manque un port usb
c j'aime bien le principe du flip
savourant place à table est à la maison
plutôt cool dites moi ce que vous en
pensez vous en bas en commentaire quant
à nous on se retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler d'eux a parlé de teck
vous le savez de l'amour
très vite tôt
[Musique]